وضيفي من اسطنبول الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي العقيده ركن حاتم كريم
الفلاحي عقيد حاتم مرحبا بك معى وكيف تقرا
مثل هذا المعطى
الاعلان يوميا تقريبا في المرحله الاخيره
حتى يعني في الايام الاخيره عن مقتل
المزيد من الضباط والجنود من وحدات
النخبه نعم تحيه لك ومشاهدي قناه الجزيره
يعني لا شك ب ان مقتل الضباط به بهذه
الاعداد الكبيره حقيقه ومن الويه النخبه
يعطي دلاله واضحه على ذراه المعارك في
داخل مدينه غزه سواء كان في القطاع
الشمالي او في القطاع الجنوبي وبالتالي
سقوط هؤلاء الضباط من النخبه يعطي دلاله
واضحه على ان هذه القطعات هي مستهدفه بشكل
كبير جدا عندما توضع الخطط العسكريه لابد
ان توضع خطط لضرب مراكز الثقل لدى العدو
فبالتالي عندما توضع الخطط يتم مثلا في
القوه الجيش او القوه العسكريه عندما توضع
القوه العسكريه يجب ان توضع اهداف من ضمن
القوه العسكريه اي من هذه القطعات التي
تشكل خطر على على المدافع او على الموضع
الدفاعي اكثر من بقيه القطعات الاخرى لذلك
عندما يحدد بانه هذه الالويه او هذه
القطعات التي تسمى النخبه هي تشكل مركز
ثقل بالنسبه للجيش الصهيوني بالنسبه
للقطاعات البريه يتم وضع الخطط اللازمه
لاستهداف هذه القطعات بشكل قوي وكبير جدا
الامر الذي يؤدي الى حصول خسائر في هذه
القطعات مما يؤدي الى تدني اداء القطعات
العسكريه في الميدان فلذلك عمليه سقوط
خسائر من الضباط بهذه الكثره وعدد كبير من
الجنود في قطعات النخبه التي تشكل الالويه
الثلاثه اللي هي جفعاتي وغاني والويه
المظليين يعطي دلاله واضحه على ان العدو
يتكبد خسائر كبيره جدا اثناء عمليه
الاقتحام التي جرت سواء كانت في القطاع
الشمالي او في القطاع الجنوبي هذا الامر
قد يجبر العدو على عمليه اعاده حساباته في
مساله وضع الخطط باتجاه مدينه غزه يضاف
الى ذلك بان هذه الخسائر اذا ما استمرت
على هذه الوتيره فانا اعتقد بانها ستؤثر
بشكل كبير جدا على اداء القطاعات العسكريه
المتواجده ضمن القطاع مما يؤثر على الخطط
التي وضعها الجيش في مساله مساله الدخول
الى قطاع غزه والاسترا على ادائها كيف
يؤثر على ادائها عندما يسقط مثلا ضابط من
وحدات النخب الاداء العسكري
لباقي الجنود والموجودين ضمن هذه الوحدات
من القوات
المقاتله ما حجم التاثير وكيف يكون على
الارض نعم حجم التاثير يكون كبير لعده
اسباب اولا بان الضباط يعتبرون هو منظومه
القياده والسيطره الرئيسيه التي تعمل على
تنفيذ الخطط الصادره من القياده العليا
وبالتالي وجود هؤلاء الضباط على راس
قطاعاتهم ومن ذو فتره طويله بمعنى ان هناك
انماط من التدريبات ومن التكتيكات التي تم
الاتفاق عليها للتنفيذ فعندما يتم اصابه
هؤلاء الضباط ويتم تبديلهم بضباط جدد
هؤلاء يحتاجون الى فتره لكي يتاقلم مع
القطعات التي تقاتل في في الميدان يضاف
الى ذلك بان القطعات التي تحت امرتهم
عندما يتم اصابه الضباط تكون هناك ردود
فعل نفسيه وتدني للمعنويات بشكل كبير جدا
الامر الذي يؤدي الى كسر اراده المقاتل
على القتال وبالتالي من هذا المنطلق تكون
العمليات العسكريه التي تاتي كعمليات
نوعيه بمقتل هذه القيادات وخصوصا القيادات
الوسطيه التي تعتبر
حلقه الوصل ما بين القيادات العليا وما
بين القطعات المتدنيه حسب الرتب برتبه
ملازم وملازم اول ونقيب تسبب اشكال
اشكاليه كبيره جدا بالنسبه للقطاعات وهذا
يحتاج الى وقت لغرض التعويض ولغرض اخلاء
الخسائر وتبديل القطاعات هذا الامر يؤدي
على يؤدي الى تدني كفاءه القطاعات
العسكريه وتدني ادائها القتالي في ارض
الميدان ا عميد عقيد حاتم ايضا عندما
نتحدث بان هذه الالويه تم الزج بها على
الارض وهذه الوحدات تحديدا جفعاتي وجولان
واللواء المظليين ايضا
يعني هو من اجل غرض عمليه التمشيط
والاجتياح البري وتامين
المكان من الناحيه الارضيه كيف ينعكس ذلك
على هذه الخطط خاصه بان قوات الاحتلال ما
تنفذه في هذه المرحله هي محاولات بسط
السيطره العسكريه على الارض وعمليات
التمشيط في
بدايتها نعم دعيني اصحح مساله التمشيط
يعني عمليه التطهير تسمى في المناطق
المبنيه وبالتالي نحن امام مراحل متعدده
عندما
يقوم المهاجم بالهجوم على المناطق المبنيه
بدايه يبدا بعمليه العزل والتطويق وبذلك
بعد ان يتم العزل والتطويق يتم التوغل الى
داخل المناطق المبنيه عن طريق تاسيس موق
موطع قدم في هذه المناطق ثم بعد ذلك تحاول
القطاعات ان تدفع شيئا فشيئا الى داخل
المناطق المبنيه عندما يتم سيطره على هذه
المناطق تبدا عمليه تطهير عمليه التطهير
هي اصعب جزء في العمليه العسكريه في
القتال في المناطق المبنيه لانه يجب على
القطعات ان تدخل جميع المنازل جميع
المنازل وجميع الطوابق وبالتالي هذا يحتاج
الى وقت ويحتاج الى قطاعات عسكريه كبيره
لغرض التنفيذ كما ان هذا الامر لا يمكن ان
يتم تحت تحت التهديد المباشر او الالتحام
والتماس المباشر مع القطعات المدافعه هذا
يحتاج الى وضع مستتب
ووضع مستقر نوعا ما نسبيا يعني حتى تستطيع
القطعات من القيام بواجباتها بهذا الامر
لذلك انا اعتقد بان مساله التطهير ستاخذ
وقت طويل ولا يمكن للقطعات الان اللي
موجوده في داخل القطاع ان تقوم بهذا الامر
خصوصا وان هناك عمليات تنطلق على هذه
القطعات التي سيطرت على بعض المناطق
وتوغلت فيها وهناك عمليات رد بهجوم مقابل
على هذه القطعات لذلك اعتقد بان هذه
القضيه تاخذ
وقت وعمل التطير عقيد حات عملل التطهير
كما تتحدث عنه في المدن عندما يكون هناك
ابنيه سليمه هي ربما تاخذ وقت وصعبه
وعندما يجري هدم البيوت هذا ما تلجا اليه
قوات الاحتلال كيف تتاثر هذه العمليات هل
تجري الامور بالتالي لصالحها ام تتعقد
اكثر ميدانيا على
الارض نعم هذا سيعتمد على كيفيه توضيح
تظيف هذه المناطق يعني بالنسبه للمدافع ان
عمليه توظيف الارض تعتبر نقطه رئيسيه
وجوهر في مساله القتال في المناطق المبنيه
يضاف الى ذلك بان عمليه الحصول على
المعلومات ايضا هي مهمه بالنسبه للمدافع
خصوصا وان المهاجم يتقدم في العراء
وبالتالي هو واهن امام القطعات المدافعه
سواء كانت في بنايات متكامله او سواء كان
في بنايات متهدم يؤخذ عليها النظره بانه
لا يتواجد احد في هذه البنايات بحيث يمكن
ان يتحول هذا الركام من الانقاظ الى مناطق
ستر لكثير من المقاتلين الذين يحاولون ان
ينفذون بشكل فردي لان العمل في المناطق
المبنيه هو عمل لام مركزي خصوصا وان هناك
قطعات نظاميه تواجه تواجه قطعات مدافعه
غير نظاميه في هذه المنطقه وبالتالي
المدافع يتمتع بنوع من اللامركزيه تمنحه
مرونه كبيره جدا في العمل وتمنحه ايضا
امكانيه للمناوره في مناطق متعدده ومن
مناطق متعدده لذا هو ف يكون تكون له
خيارات جيده في اختيار الوقت المناسب
والمكان المناسب للتنفيذ وهذا يؤثر بشكل
كبير جدا على المهاجم الذي يتقدم في هذه
المناطق ش شكرا جزيلا لك من اسطنبول
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي العقيد الركن
حاتم كريم الفلاحي